Brian you were also a young entrepreneur
weren't you I wouldn't say that but
didn't your father get what did he eat
he wanted you to sell
was it cellophane you what to do so my
parents came upon a truck of cellophane
somehow I was asked not to ask too many
questions I didn't I just suddenly there
was a basement filled with cellophane
and they encouraged me to go to school
and see if I could sell it to my
teachers or put a few in my backpack and
try and hock them at recess you know
convince kids that they might be good
stocking stuffers for their parents what
do you mean oh what's the use as oh hi
I'd know the name but I don't know what
you do with it you know you wrap
sandwiches in it it keeps things fresh
oh I'm sorry no no it was an important
question you yeah
I'm not doing a good job of selling it
obviously well did you said it there's
still some left if you're interested
nice is someone the dream was someone
would just say I'll take all of it never
happened it's a weird story
[Laughter]
Harrison famously you worked as a
carpenter in your early life but you
studied woodwork with your father but he
wasn't that good
my dad was in advertising and any he
liked to make things and we were down in
the in the basement working on building
a table and he cut off his finger wasn't
funny I thought I was 16 years old I had
not much experience with this but I I
wrapped my hand my dad's hand up and I
got him upstairs to live and I called
the police and I and then I ran
downstairs and I picked up the finger
and I put it in Kleenex and this is a
long time ago so when I got to the
emergency ward I said and it's anyone
[Laughter]
because it was awhile ago and they
didn't really even think about trying to
attach me you had some cellophane yeah
thank you